uh child rights when it comes to fathers
do you think that there's enough support
for fathers single fathers when it comes
to like support
if they're like a single father because
you know women get bailed out there's no
social support as a society in general
we're done socially we don't encourage
people go on go and be a better father
all right go go and fix things or just
get back with her the child needs you
you know go go to work go and get a
second job make more money go on
education yeah it's always it's always
that men have to be more yeah it's like
women are less than ever asking for more
from men than ever the question
like what I said women women dictate
what they want and men will succumb to
what they want these guys that are back
that are getting the girls it's no
coincidence they know what it takes to
get girls
and you have to get to a certain level
to be everybody knows that guy who used
to get all the girls in school there was
something about him that men have to
Aspire to if they want that kind of life
I think this is why Andrew Tate blew up
because men were fixated on his
lifestyle he was very true about
how he got to it he's not saying
everyone's gonna get to it but if you
want this kind of Lifestyle as a man you
have to improve you have to so are you
saying no men just need to support
themselves literally it's the only way
we live in a feminized world now we're
telling men oh it's all right to you
know succumb to some emotions nah pick
yourself up and go and get a job
straight like I I told my young my young
boys all the time there's I've got a
friend who comes to mind immediately
this man cannot live without a girl
like he's a young man he's an
able-bodied man but he jumps from
relationship to a relationship and and
it got to a point where he was with one
of his ex-girlfriends I saw this two
years before it started she was she was
a straight-headed leveled girl
went to work was never a weekend girl I
said and he was a weekend guy always out
doing drugs smoking drinking he had no
ambition and I said to him it's only
amount of time before she leaves you
because you're not displaying the
masculine qualities that every woman
wants especially when they get high in
the corporation rather and lo and behold
it happened so as a result of that I
can't tell him to just comfort him with
with beautiful words to say oh it's
going to be all right fix up
I think I think with that I don't
disagree with you I think men need a lot
especially the men nowadays they need a
step-by-step process yeah when you talk
about
um Andrew Tate that's the reason why you
know he literally had young boys in the
palm of his hand and still does he
resonates as a matter of fact because
they they want that they want and he I'm
not sure with his guideline to get that
because I don't subscribe to it
personally because I've found my own
lane every man needs to find their own
lane there's a perfect example like I
like to look at biblical stories because
it really explains the Mantra of Life at
times in the beginning of in the Bible
when God created Adam
the first thing he showed him was
himself
he created relationship with God the
second thing he showed Adam was the
garden
he gave him purpose he gave him a drive
he gave him a means of provision
third thing he showed Adam was Eve
in contrast do you know the first thing
God told you
Adam
so men inherently know in order to take
care of a woman you have to have a
purpose you have to find that's why men
struggle to settle when they're not in
any position or provision and you can't
follow the woman's leave but otherwise
you're going to eat the apple
she's gonna manipulate you somewhere
else they walk London
see the Bible is pretty red pill when
you no it's real it really it really is
and I know I don't want to go on a
religious uh Mantra here but in terms of
masculinity and fatherhood I don't think
there's anything better an example of
what what a man is that's displayed in
many biblical stories even even even to
the point of polygamous men I mean it
ain't the best example I'm just saying
but
King Solomon was one of the richest men
in his day and it said plainly in the
Bible he had many wives but the rate the
way he was able to cater to many wives
was due to resources this is exactly
what Andrew Tate saying it's not news to
me like men know what it takes to get
this lifestyle and if you want to attain
to it these are the steps it's always
been like that it's always been like
that okay I'm gonna take a second to
read some super yeah go for it too okay
um so guys make sure you like the video
as you guys know a like it's the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out in the algorithm also
um all of the super chats are going
towards a new camera so we can shoot in
8k
um we also want to get what would you
say eight cameras total
yeah yeah he said yeah
um in the studio where are you gonna put
them
everywhere everyone gets a camera it'll
be like Oprah like you get a camera
Okay so
super chats it has really helped us up
the studio quality yeah yeah like this
is we've come a long way right we really
have from sweating in that freaking one
bedroom okay
um otherworldly Oddities TV um brought
in the socks cap your mom should have
taught you the ways of a woman asking
women to protect a man from other woman
is feminine at best more humans are
absolutely barbaric we haven't changed
much let civilization break it down and
see how bad things get 90 Frito Pi Pi
equals apple pie Pearl YouTube sensors
are super chats we have to edit heavily
please read better learn internet linga
read slower too why did you skip my
question about abortion remember Hitler
had 403s mgtow by Logic felons have more
kids per capita because dark Triad
traits are attractive to women and are
correlated to women to people who commit
crimes so women don't like criminals
they like the traits but the point
stands the stat is true big Breezy no
they're attracted to these type of men
because it's unintegrated and obtuse
dominant Behavior as they got older they
look for the same thing but they're
integrated virgins Matt butcher spoiled
privilege looked good looks good equals
pain in the ass every single time Tim
nurath I am only going to say this bro
you need to learn how to forgive
forgiveness is the healing of all
problems doesn't matter who started
doesn't matter who started it or not
forgive move on be an adult you think
you're you are you think you are but
you're not acting like one Mori you're
allowing your father to win he still has
too much power over you psychologically
learn to overcome that mental block
brother 90 Frito pie pro-choice would
you oh I read that one already okay
wow I just realized the time yeah
um before we get closing
um
I just want to ask everyone you can go
around just have your final thoughts
um
how essential do you think
fatherhood is for society
100
the most fundamental aspect
of our human structure going forward
as a race of people collectively
go on
yeah just like he said it's
I can't overstate
how essential a father a male figure but
a father particularly is in a child's
life for both boys and girls I've got
I've got twin boys and a girl
the way my daughter looks at me
and the way my son looks at me is a
Feeling
that and I can never understand a state
when you have as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible